[Music]
who hasn't been there
sitting comfortably at home deciding to
watch an adrenaline field action movie
with friends
there's one essential component of any
blockbuster though
and that's well choreographed fight
scenes whether it be a fistfight a
gunfight or a mixture of the two
so in today's original we introduce you
to the by far
10 best fights in movie history so
grab your popcorn and let's go with
marvel movies you're more used to epic
cg
packed battles than brutal hand-to-hand
fighting for life and death
but 2014's captain america the winter
soldier quickly proved us wrong
because marvel not only provided badass
action in the film
but also a top-notch meme template that
has enjoyed great popularity
ever since what at first seems like a
normal elevator right
quickly turns out to be a big ambush as
captain america has to deal with several
opponents at once in the
tightest of spaces and best close combat
technique he takes out one after the
other only to be surprised by a special
unit in front of the elevator shortly
before the end
so the only way left is throw a glass
wall
followed by rather painful impact
a truly enthralling scene especially
considering that captain america has to
fight the big adversary group in such a
confined space
with his movie gladiator from the year
2000 ridley scott created a real
masterpiece
as a gladiator the main character
maximus is of course often led to his
own devices
but the following scene is really
wonderful to watch in a gladiator fight
he not only has to fight
the strong tigress of golf but he also
has to confront the tigers chained
all around him like every good fight
this one has perfectly practiced fight
scenes and of course
a victorious maximus at the end of the
day a truly worthy exhibition fight for
an already epic
film old boy from 2003 is a thrilling
revenge thriller that heats up
considerably towards the
end one scene however lingers in every
viewer's mind and that's when main
character
oh they soon armed only with a hammer
fights his way through a corridor full
of merciless enemies
eventually even with a knife in his back
pretty impressive how he manages to keep
getting back on his feet against a horde
of almost two dozen
enemies taking them out one by one it's
almost a bit reminiscent of john wick
isn't it and of course john wick
aka baba yaga should not be missing from
this list
in part 3 from 2019 especially the fight
scene from the glass room sticks in mind
surrounded by countless skulls the
opponents are in for a brutal fight
against the professional killer
he cleverly uses his fragile
surroundings to his advantage and shows
no mercy
in particular after he has picked up his
weapon
even though he himself has thrown
through the glass cabinets often enough
he still holds the upper hand in this
fight for life and death
not less impressive is one of the
struggles at the beginning where he has
to defend himself against even more
adversaries
fortunately he is surrounded by numerous
knives and blades during this scene
and as can be seen he is able to throw
them
quite well the highlight is
unquestionably at the end of the scene
because damn that really hit the eye
the indonesian film the raid 2 is packed
with action from front to back anyway
but one scene stands out among all the
other fights
mendes of course the famous kitchen
scene near the end which is described by
many as the best choreographed fight in
film history for a good reason
the merging of vision sound and above
all emotion is what makes the 10 minute
long sequence so unique
main character rama gets to deal with
his former friend uku and completely
tears apart the kitchen in the process
every blow and each evasive action is so
perfectly coordinated that you can't
help
but be amazed rama then delivers the
finishing blow to his old companion with
a karambit
knife leading actor aiko ui remembers
the shooting of the scene very clearly
since the entire team worked on this
moment for
over half a year to ensure that
everything was perfect
to then find the right camera angle for
the respective move almost resembles a
master stroke
in our opinion it was definitely worth
it in the end
because this scene is truly an
outstanding
piece of film history and the monster
movie king kong from
2005 the giant ape has to deal with not
just one
but three t-rexes in a nearly seven
minute long scene
kang does everything he can to avoid
leaving and narrow to the ravenous
dinosaurs
this is followed by spectacular moves
and
really not to be envied protagonist
because whiplash is definitely
inevitable here
after defeating his last enemy the
gorilla briefly tries his skills as an
oral surgeon
and enjoys the virtual applause of the
audience with some vigorous pounding on
his
chest andy circus who convincingly
brings out king kong's emotions with the
help of motion capture
obviously contributed greatly to the
scene deservedly the film also won an
award for best visual effects at the
oscars
even today you can watch the scene which
is over 15 years old without being
reminded that a lot has changed in terms
of cgi
and computer effects in the meanwhile
the 1981 classic indiana jones and the
raiders of the lost ark proves that you
don't always need green screen and the
latest technology for spectacular fights
jones has to deal with the giant new
would probably have broken the
archaeologist in two inside of a boxing
ring
but jones of course also knows how to
make clever use of his surroundings and
deals with his opponent not only with
kicks to the abdomen but also with dry
desert sand
in the eyes luckily the wehrmacht
realized the whole spectacle rather late
which is why indiana jones has plenty of
time to hunt down the giant with a
little support
shortly before jones and his female
companion escape the giant learns in a
rather unpleasant way why one should
never look at a rotating airplane
propeller
up close the action-packed exit of the
two is then topped off by a lovely
explosion christian bale and liam neeson
gave us an equally adrenaline-filled
fight scene in the 2005 film
batman begins the conflict between bruce
wayne and rozelle gould takes place on a
moving train is perfectly staged by
director christopher nolan
while gordon is awkwardly attempting to
give batman an advantage with his
batmobile he blows up a bridge pillar
which means certain
death for all occupants in case it
crashes
since batman's moral code forbids
killing his opponent he decides to save
himself just before the wagon falls
leaving all ghoul behind as it is not
against his principles not to save
someone the sequence ends with a
spectacular crash of the train and a
triumphant batman gliding through gotham
city thereafter freddy vs jason from
2003 is the only one in this list to
belong to the horror genre
but it is by no means less action-packed
than other movies
the battle between the two horror icons
freddy krueger and jason voris is
initially slow to get started
this changes abruptly when actress
laurie manages to lure the two evil
creatures to chris lake by means of a
trick
this is where the trouble really begins
the physically superior jason makes
freddy look like a complete fool at the
beginning of the fight and gives him a
hard time in the burning hut
a ruthless fight develops between the
two icons though
ultimately it's not really clear which
one of the two will emerge victorious
in the end both seem to have somehow won
and lost at the same time
nevertheless this fight is really
something to behold
with superpowers it's of course much
easier to fight through huge hordes of
enemies
that's certainly what thor actor chris
hemsworth must have thought in thor
ragnarok as his character
effortlessly finds his way forward bit
by bit on a footbridge
after activating his superpowers
meanwhile led zeppelin's immigrant song
plays and you don't even know which way
to look anymore
in the end loki was most certainly
grateful for the friendly support
which fight do you think is missing and
should we take a closer look at battles
from movies like lord of the rings and
avengers end game
please let us know in the comments
[Music]
you